it's an ecosystem of people who help
people and if you think of it
professionals you think of people who
dedicate
technically the
uh their profession is to help others
and to help businesses run smoothly
and this is actually the person that
gets uh in many cases most yell that so
there is a lot of work doing with this
industry to
to well position it and to push it
further and that's basically i would say
what i'm looking for
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by home adventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today we are with you have
mahlin the vice president of marketing
at atera yov has over 10 years of
experience leading multi-channel
marketing performance and growth
operations today uav is the vice
president of marketing at atera which
recently raised more than a hundred
million dollars to help small businesses
to proactively manage their networks
maintaining them problem-free
[Music]
welcome to 20-minute leaders thank you
so much for joining me how are you today
thank you michael i'm all well how are
you
i'm doing great i'm doing great another
conversation about a a fascinating
journey
going from iit and computer systems in
mamram to various
marketing roles business unit roles now
vice president of marketing at a terra a
company that has raised significant
significant amount of funds i believe
most recently 77 million dollars uh
looking at the rmm
uh software and
i love the headline rmm software that
doesn't suck
there aren't many i heard many places
that i can see that is the headline and
i love that so
we'll hear all about that in just a
minute but but you have to walk me
through some of the big milestones in
your own career and journey and how do
you because how do you envision yourself
if you
sort of take yourself to a third party
you know condition how do you see you of
macklin's journey throughout his career
oh wow that's that's a big question you
have martin's journey i will say first
of all we all deserve a software that
doesn't suck so we'll talk about that
more
but uh but that's uh it's not
in the title just for being there we
have a lot of thinking process behind it
and i will share hey you have macklin's
journey i would say
first of all
again thank you for having me and i will
tell you that in terms of
a marketer i i see it as a big
contribution from my end to society and
i will explain
the as i said right
and as i see marketing it's matchmaking
but for businesses and for
needs and products and services and
always i thought to myself what can i do
that will
will do good and i thought and i
realized that i'm very good at
making these type of matches so all of
my journey i would say is a written with
that in mind
and uh
i started selling music online to
a new new musicians through icq at the
time
actually
just before the army go to the icu
and really from there i realized that
really marketing is my thing and i
started learning it along with the idea
as you mentioned with information
systems
and um with time i took uh the different
roles you mentioned so it's all about
really taking care of the
matching between customers and needs and
the product and services by definition
so in your entrance to
when you're entranced to marketing
you really saw that you see what i'm
saying from you but we got you excited
about marketing it wasn't you know just
the selling and the strategy of how to
close the sale the fastest it's really
is about finding the win-win situation
between the business and the customer
that needs it
exactly that's exactly it my
i would say that my first role as a
marketer as an intern was actually in
affiliate marketing and in affiliate
marketing i found the
way to do
win-win online what i liked also in
performance marketing afterwards i was
uh almost eight years at weapons before
joining atera for the for the past three
years
i would say that
when i realized what performance
marketing can do which is basically
customization of messaging but for the
masses making sure that we can do
almost like one-on-one messaging but
on scale that were that's where i fell
in love with the with really what they
do for the past i would say you know 12
13 years
incredible what makes you you have a
good marketer do you think obviously you
know if you look at your trajectory and
you look at what you're doing today
you're by any standard a good market or
a great marketer but
what makes you know if you look
you know deep inside your work
your thinking process and especially i'm
asking is because i think it resonates
to sort of the the really unique way
that you're looking at marketing which i
haven't heard before which is really
really cool
what makes you a good marketer
first of all i'm humbled and thank you
and in my mind uh
i would say what what makes good
marketing is first of all constantly
listening and understanding the users
we're talking to and we're selling to um
and that's as as you mentioned
in terms of the
matchmaking as i said we really need to
understand that we're not pushing
anything and i don't want i'm not in the
business of pushing selling stuff that
are not needed we need to understand
what is needed and we need to make sure
that we convey the message to the
relevant person and
and if it's not relevant we just move on
and we hope to leave a good experience
so once it is relevant it the the lead
potentially would become a sales so in
terms of good marketing
constantly listening and of course
knowing well what you're selling so the
both ends what we're selling knowing it
well knowing the customers and the
different users and the different
segments that's for me a key for good
marketing
and so obviously until now we've been
talking about marketing as a general
term and something that we can be
applied to any vertical from selling
eggs to a supermarket to selling a b2b
software and
you're right now in the rmm space and in
a second you'll you'll explain to me
exactly what does it mean the remote
monitoring and management for it
solutions but
if you're looking at marketing in
general over your career
what what did you find yourself most
drawn to in the types of products that
you're selling
so
first of all
online was very important for me because
as i mentioned it it was something that
it was a platform that i felt very
important and it was very connected to
it i wanted to sell globally and in
terms of the product itself
something that would
i would say for the past few years was
very important to me to uh keep on
selling products that provide value
and i.t which we'll talk about now in in
a few minutes it's not like uh the most
um it's not intuitively you think of id
when you think let's do let's push
humanity forward but you will see how
it's a it's actually
a great story with the terra we sell
mostly to small and medium businesses
and it's an ecosystem of people who help
people and if you think of id
professionals you think of people who
dedicate technically the
their profession is to help others and
to help businesses run smoothly and this
is actually the person that gets in many
cases most yell that so there is a lot
of work doing with this industry to
to well
position it and to push it further and
that's basically i would say what i'm
looking for
and what i do
wonderful so
take me through a terra and start you
know by i have to understand you know
rmm so remote monitoring and management
what does that even mean and what what
pain point is a terra solving here
sure so
first of all rmm
let's let's leave the initials for later
many initials in the iit industrial
hemisphere um atera came to as i
mentioned to serve smbs
small and medium businesses globally
it's more than half of the economy and
these are in terms of i.t it was a
population that was underserved for many
years
what the terra does it makes i.t network
monitoring and computer maintenance
proactive rather than reactive now think
of yourself to maybe put it into
day-to-day words
you have
probably on a daily of course weekly
basis computer issues your computer gets
lows slowed or the printer is about to
go down to you know to run out of ink
etc so
many issues windows gets updated and
and you're not necessarily secured
because
all of the patches that are updated are
not completely patched and what we do
is we aim that you will not need to talk
to your i.t professional at all
the the terra system is able to
recognize when there is an issue or
there is about to be an issue it alerts
the id technician that that
will fix the issue without uh basically
having you feel it and that's basically
to be proactive and maintenance mode
that rather than reactive i would add to
that that
what we also do
we have two types of i.t professionals
that are customer of ours one is ik
teams within small medium businesses and
one is msps italian initials is big for
it professionals so industry so
msps are managed service providers so
think of
small i.t businesses that
for
all of these small companies
or even one person company a doctor a
lawyer or a large or a startup that is
growing they don't have ide in-house
normally so they have msps helping them
run their business smoothly and what we
do
we enable msps a whole ecosystem not
only of reactive becoming proactive
rather than reactive we also take the
back office and automate it it's called
professional services automation so the
billing the invoicing the ticketing
all happens in parallel so for example
in the what i told you in terms of let's
assume your computer gets lower and we
see that the temperature of the computer
goes a higher and you have many browsers
opened in parallel etc
okay on top of getting an alert and
fixing the issue without you even
noticing it
the id professional will have a ticket
that is being counting the time and
eventually once it's resolved
all of the back office is being taken
care of until the invoicing
and also building later on
incorrect that's the idea basically yeah
and let them focus on what they do best
exactly let them focus on what they do
best and and and it makes a lot of sense
and so you know
looking at it from the vp marketing side
and obviously there's the whole r d
product side but and then there's also
the marketing side and the sales side
what what is the vp marketing role at a
company like this what does it look like
i mean are you more on the strategy on
the selling how granular do you get what
what is your role in essence
so
of course the strategy and the basically
the role is to
be able to take this you know these are
we selling to we're selling to smbs and
very small businesses we want to get to
them so the idea really was to build a
strategy around performance mostly
and basically be able to recognize the
needs of it professionals and tailor a
message to all like we do with b2c like
like the day-to-day consumers let's say
and uh as a vp marketing to build a
system that enables the scale
of customized
messaging for the i.t professionals that
that's a big challenge and a big role
of me day to day and also the
positioning of basically of the market
to to help them to educate them to
make sure that they are perceived well
within the organization
they serve it's also a big part of what
we do on a day-to-day basis so i would
say customized messaging inspect scale
and the positioning of the whole
industry id industry is actually an
industry as i like to say it needs to be
rebooted or reconfigured in the it works
does your
does your position change
and how often does it change and how
do you think others in the organizations
see you
so in terms of just to clarify in terms
of the of what of the day today my
position changes or how dynamic it is
the challenges day to day i think more
in sort of the in the life cycle of a
company so i mean part of the thinking
about the strategy you only you have 24
hours in the day just like anybody else
how does you how do you keep in check
with your
with your priorities as to where your
time is best spent in a company that is
growing very very quickly and is and is
continuing to grow
terra as you mentioned actually it's a
it's a great question atera when i
joined it was
it was me and also our marketing manager
which is now senior marco manager and we
started as two people now we're close to
20 people so definitely the marketing
arm changed within a terra
and terra grew quickly also from 20 30
employees at the time three years ago to
now 130 and they're growing doubling its
amount hopefully of people
in 2022
and accordingly the the
focus on
well grown up
marketing professionals within the
organization and the well-procedured
activities within the organization
is crucial okay how to keep the by the
way we work i know if it's something
that you used to work with but okay ours
is significantly significantly important
in our stage i think we're exactly the
same size as google was when you started
the implementing it they started wow so
yeah it's a
it's a great challenge we have our
inorganic arm and we have a paid
advertising arm and a very big and
growing creative arm
yeah so yeah a lot of challenges day to
day the position definitely evolves
now if you're imagining you know atera's
impact on the industry you know five ten
years down the line on small businesses
the way that i t is being you know
delivered and administered what what is
the the greater impact and the ripple
effect that this can have
on businesses and you know if businesses
do better obviously then the rest of our
services are better
for sure so i'll tell you two things as
i said one
the iit professionals and the id
profession is being recognized for what
it is this is major think of an
organization exact especially
organizations that grow bigger without
i.t without proper id
it's they will crash and that's
something that
you know when you have the minimum
necessary all the time
you don't think about it when when the
minimum
when the minimum to run your business is
actually not there
and the id can do
way more than that minimum
and this is something i would really
uh look for in five to ten years that
organizations understand the power of
i.t
that's one thing
second thing is that the organizations
themselves will run way smoother also at
terra one of the
main developments that we have is ai
based
it so anything automation so automating
the day-to-day
tasks reset your password come on i
don't need to i don't need a person to
work on recent my password the i.t
person can do way more an engineer and
build way more than that so
basically it's twofold i.t to be
recognized for the power that it is and
actually um
move and do and scale more than a in
terms of activities of what they do and
the organizations themselves to focus on
their end on better infrastructure so
they can run smoother i would say in
five to ten years
there is no doubt smbs will be like that
as the enterprises are now
much more
yeah you know leaning towards
smoothly
running
what in your journey or current position
do you enjoy most so where i mean i'm
sensing you know that there's a deep
sense of mission in where you're at i'm
sensing that there's a deep sense of
satisfaction with what you're doing and
and
and i truly believe it i mean you can
really feel it so you know what is it
about what you do that really makes you
so excited
yeah so first of all thank you it's fun
first of all it's fun actually that's
true it's fun doing what i do
i would also say that you know we we
want to make an impact and we feel it we
see we get the feedback and we we are in
touch with the
day-to-day i hear many
discussions and read a lot about
you know listening to customers and join
the sales team or join the support team
we do it ourselves we don't wait for any
external team to talk to customers we we
are happy to talk to customers and when
we get the feedback that we help to we
have the customers growing their
business growing their team running
their team
uh gets a better value from our product
we also try to
we asking customers success working a
lot together so when we get such a good
feedback
i would say that's
it means that we do
what we need to do
fantastic and let's transition out to
more about you know the professional
side of the then and getting the
inspiration for that so you know one of
the things that i that i'm always really
fascinated by is how do leaders that are
in strategic positions how do they you
know continuously get the motivation and
inspiration to make the right decisions
that then and and and having those
decisions come from a place of real
inspiration and real intrinsic
motivation so you know if you're looking
at your world and your journey where do
you derive your inspiration for the the
decisions that you make for the way that
you're thinking about your work in your
life
so
that's that's a great question i'm
thinking
you know i know my my aim so my aim is
really to make the match between the
need and yes and the product and and you
know
uh id professionals in that sense and uh
and the terra for me is that match and
that's the aim
and then data is very big for me i'm
very
uh i'm very data minded i'm trying to
not be too data-minded sometimes because
i mean because being open is also very
important in that sense but
data is what
i would say the motivation is clear but
what keeps me on track is
analyzing i know the data
a to z let's say and z2 and backwards so
and if i'm not i'm
constantly uh try to learn what's
missing so i would say definitely data
while knowing the aim that's the two
things that
keeps me running
if you have to think of a few words that
would describe you and your journey
what are those few words
um okay
your words first of all that i care i
think it's yes
100 i can feel that
that's that's really that's that that's
the basic
um
secondly i would say that i'm
open-minded and thirdly i would say that
i'm uh focused trying to be very focused
on what i do
thank you very very much thank you for
um you know showing me a marketing in a
little bit of a different light and a
different way of thinking through
marketing which is really really
wonderful and i appreciate your time and
your energy and and the the way that
you're working with small businesses to
really make an impact something that you
know in a place that maybe not is the
sexiest place that you know 25 year olds
out of the army want to go in and think
of but but truly making a significant
impact on the world and and at the end
on everything that we that these small
businesses get to produce and so thank
you for the great work and stay safe and
stay healthy
thank you michael for the great words
and uh and stay well as well and uh
thank you thank you bye